يبدو أننا
نسمع الكثير من النسخ الاحتياطية خلال فترة
رئاسة ترامب ، ومع ذلك خمنوا من لا يزال
الرئيس يطالب الديموقراطيون مجلس
النواب بفتح تحقيق لعزل
الرئيس دونالد ترامب مشيرًا إلى ما
يعتبرونه جرائم عديدة
مثل العرقلة  العدالة
تنتهك بند المكافآت في
الدستور من أجل إفادة
أعماله والشيء الصغير الذي أدعوه
تقويض حرية الصحافة ،
لكن ليس بهذه السهولة ، هناك طريق طويل
لمساءلة رئيس أمريكي في منصبه بنجاح ،
تنص المادة 1 ، القسم 2 من الدستور المذكور ، على
هذا  اقتبس من
مجلس النواب يجب أن يختار
رئيسه والمسؤولين الآخرين ، ويكون
له السلطة الوحيدة للمساءلة والاقتباس ،
لذا يجب أن تبدأ عملية العزل في المجلس
، وسيحتاج المجلس بكامله إلى
تفويض إحدى لجانه عادةً
اللجنة القضائية
للتحقيق مع الشخص في  السؤال عما إذا كانت اللجنة قد
قررت أن هناك البعض هناك
يمكنها إرسال مقالاتها  من المساءلة
إلى المجلس بكامل هيئته ، ثم
يصوت المجلس بأغلبية بسيطة
الآن نظرًا لأن الديمقراطيين يسيطرون على المنزل في
الوقت الحالي ، يمكنهم بسهولة القيام بذلك
على طول الخطوط الحزبية مثل الغد ، لكن
هذا سيكون مجرد الخطوة الأولى ، المادة ،
القسم الثاني ، يرسل الأمر برمته
إلى  يقتبس مجلس الشيوخ
، يجب أن يكون لمجلس الشيوخ السلطة الوحيدة لمحاكمة جميع
دعاوى الإقالة عند جلوسه لهذا
الغرض ، يجب أن يحلفوا اليمين أو
التأكيد عندما
يحاكم رئيس الولايات المتحدة ،
يجب أن يترأس رئيس الولايات المتحدة ولا يجوز إدانة أي شخص
دون موافقة
ثلثا الأعضاء الحاضرين
والاقتباس الآن من المريح أنه
يبدو أن كل شخص تقريبًا في الكونجرس هو
محامٍ بالفعل لأن دعوى العزل في مجلس الشيوخ
تنطوي على محاكمة
حيث يكون أعضاء مجلس النواب
وأعضاء مجلس الشيوخ هم
الثلثين الأغبياء  من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ سيحتاجون
إلى التصويت لإدانة القليل من
الظرف ، ستخبرك الرياضيات أن
هناك 67 عضوًا على الأقل من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ ومع
انهيار الحزب الحالي الذي يعني أن
20 عضوًا جمهوريًا ضخمًا
سيحتاجون إلى التصويت لعزل ترامب على
افتراض أن كل ديمقراطي صوت أيضًا
بهذه الطريقة